Jeff Green went from having his heart
stopped for a whole hour during open
heart surgery back in 2012. going on to
play 11 more seasons in the NBA and now
winning an NBA title this year with the
Nuggets Jeff Green owes his life to a
simple physical with the Boston Celtics
because it was those doctors who
recognized something was not right the
surgeon who performed green surgery said
that his aorta was on the verge of
rupturing he said it was paper thin and
that it could have been a major disaster
if they didn't catch his condition in
time many thought Green's basketball
career was over and green also said that
a lot of teams told him he wouldn't make
it more than five years in the league he
missed the 2011-2012 season but then
came back the next year and he played 81
games with the Celtics now he celebrates
two birthdays one on the day he was born
August 28th and then one when his heart
stopped and then started again on
January 9th he says that every morning
when he wakes up and every night before
he goes to bed he looks at his scar and
thanks God for the blessing of life that
he has been given